Beyonce gets candid about one of her
hardest life lessons it was a big part
of my story it was one of the hardest
things I've been through Queen B covers
Elle's January issue and inside the mag
she opens up in an interview conducted
by direct messages Facebook messages and
emails with fans about how having
multiple miscarriages made her rethink
her work specifically around the Grammys
where she won only two awards for her
2017 album lemonade quote I began to
search for deeper meaning when life
began to teach me lessons I didn't know
I needed success looks different to me
now I learned that all pain and loss is
in fact a gift having miscarriages
taught me that I had to mother myself
before it could be a mother to someone
else Beyonce's husband jay-z first
revealed Beyonce had miscarried in his
2012 song glory salams and stars
Beyonce also discussed the tragic
experience in her 2013 documentary life
is but a dream about two years ago I was
pregnant for the first time and I heard
the heartbeat which was the most
beautiful music I've ever heard in my
life that's something that happens when
you hear the heartbeat it makes you
truly know that there's life inside of
you calling it the saddest thing she
ever went through I picked out names I
envisioned what my child look like I
pull back to New York to get my checkup
and no heartbeat
of course the couple eventually welcomed
three kids to the world
seven-year-old blue and two year old
twins Sir Andrew me
Beyonce tells the mad quote I had blue
and the quest for my purpose became so
much deeper I died and was reborn in my
relationship and the quest for self
became even stronger she added it's
difficult for me to go backwards being
number one was no longer my priority my
true win is creating art and a legacy
that will live far beyond me that's
fulfilling the 38 year old singer also
opened up about the changes to her body
post pregnancy I feel free I feel very
empowered children and maturity have
taught me to value myself beyond my
physical appearance and really
understand that I am more than enough no
matter what stage I'm at in life she
added that giving zero is the most
liberating place to be I feel the
happiest I've ever been in my life
[Music]